Oh, this was a lot of questions in one question. So I had to make it small. Just an update. I've had my first of first three of six RGCC.
Um, uh, Vax, um, prep injections about my second week off and next week start up again for the next four or six injections. My ankles have been swollen for the last three plus days.
I started using the right swelling program a few days ago. They are still swollen last month. They were swollen for about a week. Didn't use the right fit it went away. What might be causing my ankles to swell. So usually when your ankles are swelling, um, it has to do with them with them.
Uh, yes, you start taking a salted tank that can cause some swelling of the ankles.
Uh, heart function is your one of your first things you think of with swollen ankles. Um, uh, any impingement, um, uh, clothing or sitting for a long period of time, your ankles drain through the lip system to the inferior.
The cable that goes back to the heart, um, through the iliac veins that come through your gloid area. So if there's any impingement in that area, it could cause ankles to swell.
Um, if that is a problem after, um, that doesn't go away. You certainly would be wise to get your heart checked out too.
Um, that's you can always have a cold morbidity. You always have the ability to have one thing to wait on. I don't know if you're dealing with cancer or everything you think it was tied to cancer.
For several weeks each morning when I wake up, I feel pretty good, but within two hours, I'm exhausted.
So I do not have much activity. I have been running the right energy and vitality program have not both a city change.
Um, remember your lip system drains by action up your muscles, your lip system doesn't drain by action of your heart.
So this might be tied to the last question above. So just trying to move your ankles even if you're sitting in a lazy boy chair, start writing the alphabet with your feet, um, getting, getting motion in there.
Even if you're tired, try to stand up and do some leg lifts or some type of simple exercises, um, can be helpful, can get motion, motion is the key motion is the key to life, just always remember that.
So when you're not moving because you're sitting at a computer all day working like sometimes I am or your, or you're just exhausted and you're laid out all day that can lead to worse problems.
So you want to get up and move around, do some squats, do a little bit of exercises, do something to move your body.
This simple little calisthenic type exercises, it doesn't have to be something or only just needs something that's increasing motion can be really helpful.
The past three weeks, I've developed a dry cough.
Suggestions for getting rid of that could this be for the purged older of the tumor, maybe, um, I'm concerned about your lungs and anybody has a cough on concern about your lungs.
Go back to home page of the member site and look at the recipe for nebulizing hydro your proxide.
And again, that is just a great thing to do for any issues that's going on in your lungs.
If you've got any fungal infection, any any pneumonia issues, the one of the main causes of comorbidity with cancer is pneumonia, and it's oftentimes undiagnosed, um, pneumonia.
So, uh, you don't want that to start happening. So, um, go go back and think about nebulizing hydro proxide for your lungs.
My skin is purple on my right collarbone area and below my deck.
It's personally sent me photos where the collarbones meet the skin is starting to flake off and it's very thin.
Any suggestions to the skin doesn't break open.
What about you the crib seal and carrier, or this is a, um, a, a, uh, oil that a person could get from, you know, the, uh, from their, if they happen, if they're using a, um, one of my trying to think of the ones here.
Essential oil company.
So, you can get that from young living, you can get that from an essential oil company that you might be going through to, to use an essential oil.
And this can be good for skin issues as well.
I would also think of just using olive oil or coconut oil on it can be beneficial as well.
That could be beneficial for your skin.
We have a company oil, uh, company sound that could be really good.
We also have, we have some new tabs that you're going to look at that are really nice.
They could be really good for your skin benefit. We have a holiday skin special.
Can you please send me by genetic results on the variance? Yes, I actually sent those to you.
I already, but I just sent you them again today, but you have that blocker of your email.
And I always have to put in, you know, my name and information so the email will go through.
Maybe that's why it's not going through.
So I already sent it to you three times. You didn't get it. Please let us know. We'll try it again.